pride month and an offshore island two
words you never want to hear in the same
sentence together I of course want to
get a glimpse into what's really going
on at Pride Island however typically
straight CIS white males like myself
aren't welcome at recruitments we're not
trying to recruit I mean events like
this so how do we blend in well first we
gotta get into character
we're going undercover to expose the
secrets of what's really going on at an
LGT Island Pride event we've all seen
Twitter lately will there actually be
kids at this event
[Music]
we're not taking advantage of anyone
will they be trying to hide what's going
on he is Satan and he respects his son's
pronouns because he is expensive time to
find out
my name is misery
[Applause]
and this is my little doggy friend
for me
oh
wow I'm surprised you have kids dancing
[Applause]
[Music]
can't make this up we come to a pride
event and we're watching a kid dance for
five minutes
job
[Applause]
posted up here with the and the
kids honestly bro I did not expect to
see kids here some online Social Media
stuff and people go without a proportion
but this is insane to see if
there's little kids here and there's
kids dancing in front of everyone with
dudes dresses girls
[Music]
so just imagine think about how many
people here are just like part of a rock
right now they're all gay
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
give me a little bit more baby
give me a little bit more
all right I'm in a sticky situation here
the drag queen wants to get me on stage
to dance with them which I definitely
don't want to do but maybe actually that
isn't such a bad idea
I know you trying to dance with me you
know what he told me he said I'm white I
have no rhythm
[Applause]
baby
what's your name
Sonny Sonny
are you the light
uh oh y'all got that one huh y'all got
them come here we're gonna get you in
the middle now we gonna put on some
music for sunny and we're gonna see what
Sunny got to break down give me that
cocktail for your pool you see I stick
out like a sore thumb here my disguise
is a rainbow Boston shirt with the tag
still on it and a banana bucket hat they
can smell the Sith straight white malice
on me although it's weird I know I have
to dance with this drag queen if I want
to get a single interview with these
people
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all right all right
take no cocktails on it
thank you Sonic
[Applause]
how did your tribe
we're currently now I mean I put on the
shirt and the hat to fit in but
like there's no bro how the are we
about we're gonna be the enemies going
home like I don't think they realize
that
oh my God bro that was dude I was
standing there going like like this and
out of nowhere
all right now that we have the lgbtq
IDGAF street cred we can finally get
into interviewing them how'd you guys
like the show good we loved it are you
guys part of the LGBT
show support yeah
pride mean to you
that's what it means to me okay and what
do you think some of the biggest issues
facing the lgbtq community are right now
people not having respect and
understanding that people can do
whatever they want and living their
lives the way that they want to live
them authentically I think that people
are in their heads a lot and they're
critical because of whatever they
learned growing up but get over that
so it's it's criticism from other
people yes and what do you think the
solution to that is education education
education so showing it more in schools
and teaching them absolutely as a former
educator I think it's super important
that people make sure their kids my kid
is here and I want her to understand
that everyone is different everyone
lives a unique life and we have to
respect everyone how did you like the
show nice
adorable okay then I guess uh taking
your kids to drive shows is um teaching
them to be respectful
that's what I'm gonna do what do you
guys think some of the biggest issues
are right now facing the LGBT community
I mean we just saw a very fun drag show
but I feel like conservatives have
definitely identified drag as like
something that they can Target and that
they can like make seem like something
very like perverted and weird when it's
not so I feel like that is definitely an
issue I feel like trans kids are
definitely being targeted also
just a little video of like a vlog kind
of thing oh yeah you want to be in it I
am staff
[Music]
ride however you should talk to my Palms
team because they would probably like
this is what I would put out that's
something you're posting somewhere okay
like they think they promoted or
something yeah I mean we shared on an
Instagram story or whatever yeah that'd
be nice they just have like no white
they I think they think I'm like gay or
like I'm like with them or doing a
documentary I don't know what they think
it worked bro the dancing worked the
dancing worked for they have no idea
they're all down but that was that was
genius bro that was a chess move are you
part of the LGBT community or just here
to show support I'm just here to support
what are your pronouns
what you mean like your pronouns no
you're good you're good
eat him okay he him do you think kids
can be transgender too oh no they can
decide whatever they want but I don't
think I don't know I really don't know
how to answer that question do you think
that showing them this like drag shows
and this kind of stuff would influence
that decision it could I think he
thought it was like part of them so he
was like yeah he's like scared I just
told him straight up yo brother I'm one
of you first off like what are your
guys's pronouns I use he him pronouns
she her what do you guys think are some
of the biggest issues that the lgbtq
community faces right now uh currently
there's legislation being passed like
anti-transgender legislation I think in
particular as well as just like General
acceptance like it's not it's not super
mainstream anymore and I mean I don't
know I think I think it just needs to be
a little bit more normalized how do you
think we normalize it like start
teaching in in schools more or what's
the best move yeah I think sexual
education needs to be more inclusive
um I didn't learn about any LGBT sexual
education when I was in school
um like Middle High School maybe
elementary school but I think that in
particular that's when you need to start
learning about those things huh one big
criticism that I always see on social
media from conservatives is about
showing stuff to kids what do you guys
think of that I think kids don't give a
I don't think it's dangerous um we
have kids here today and they just think
it's fun they just saw a fun little
dancer doing a fun little dance and they
don't care
do you think that kids can be trans yeah
yeah absolutely I mean I I think a lot
of the times people don't really realize
it until they go through puberty and
realize that they hate what's happening
but it's definitely possible for them to
realize earlier countries like Uganda
they just scan gay people homosexuals
have no space in Uganda what do you
think of that and should the U.S take
action I'm really upset about it I think
the us as a richer country or just like
as a first world country has like an
obligation to help people the ugandans
gay ugandans LGBT ones because it's
wrong and it's unacceptable I feel like
we have the resources to do it we have
the money I think we have an obligation
to help other countries who don't really
know what they're doing in terms of
being safe to people so what is your
like what does your shirt mean what does
my shirt mean so it just means that when
people want to be called something they
should be respected and you should call
them what they want to be called it's
just basic respect cultures all around
the world have this basic rule it's not
an exception it's nothing weird about
that why Satan because Satan's awesome
Satan's awesome yeah are you religious
at all I am but I'm not a Satanist yeah
I have my own strange off of all
religion thing but I'm not pushing an
agenda here this is just supposed to be
fun and funny and all that since you're
talking to a guy who's a really good
studies nerd I had like multiple degrees
in religious studies I'll tell you that
Satan is oftentimes a symbol of things
on the edge or things on the outside
groups of people or individuals who have
legitimate things to do legitimate
things to say legitimate options
legitimate uh things that they want to
do with their lives but are often
rejected by the mainstream but they're
still legitimate that's kind of what
that means for me okay so like the media
portrays marginalized groups as satanic
no no no no no no no no this is not to
portray people as being satanic it's
just that Satan is a symbol of those
folks who are on the edge and some of
those folks Embrace that symbolism one
of the biggest problems I've noticed the
conservatives have with the whole
movement is about showing it to kids
that's what I've seen on social media a
lot what do you think of that showing
what to kids exactly like
[Music]
kids at drag shows for example or
teaching lgbtq stuff in school what do
you think of all that should it be
taught more or taught less kids being
exposed to these things in public in a
safe environment and learning about them
in school that's what school is for and
that's what the public arena is this
isn't dangerous none of this is
dangerous nothing nothing like this is a
threat this would be like saying other
religious groups are automatically a
threat like saying Muslims are a threat
because they're Muslim they're not it's
just another alternative it's just
another way that people can think and
live and be and lgbtq folks are the same
thing and if this fits who you are as an
individual whether you're Muslim
Satanist lgbtq it doesn't matter because
there's something dangerous there this
it's good for people to feel that they
should be accepted and have a path
forward for them that works for them
that's what's important so yes it should
be in the public okay all right thank
you that makes sense
his shirt means that he is Satan
that she respects his son's pronouns
because his son is trans his name is
Alex and I think because he is Satan it
means he respects pronouns
it's very little kid
um
I think it's hilarious that you just
asked a religious scholar about seeing
as he could have brought on for like
seven days wow yeah awesome thank you
guys for your time thank you for doing
this yeah I don't even know what to say
but I don't even know what the to
say right now what do you think are some
of the biggest problems the lgbtq
community is facing right now laws that
are trying to discriminate against queer
and trans youth okay
I would agree with that what kind of
laws are there like book Banning Banning
drag queens from performing in youth
spaces so you think that there should be
more drag queens in new spaces
I mean I think as long as people are
comfortable with it why not okay and
then what kind of books are they Banning
that are a problem books that have queer
characters in them so you want more
representation of lgbtq people yeah it's
brilliant yeah have they seen the books
have they seen the books that have
gotten banned I'm gonna pop up some of
the books right now
I've been pretty good about staying
undercover but I feel like they're like
low-key starting to pick up on it
because there's like a lot of people
looking and like giving me weird looks
right now right after I said that an LG
TV agent came over to check the
situation
we're just interviewing people with some
questions you want to do it uh what are
the questions if you don't want us to
use it we won't first off what are your
pronouns my pronouns are here ham has
okay are you part of the lgbtq community
or just here to support I work here so
I'm more helping you organize but I'm
just helping organize yeah can I ask
what this is about yeah we're just
filming like we were just doing a vlog
thing so this is my first ever Pride
event that I've come to yeah so I've
never been I just wanted to document it
sure this is great what is it for
um just a Channel of mine that's great
what's the channel it's called Sunny
we're just starting it up though that's
awesome yeah hopefully it goes big I
hope like the lgbtq community really
like picks up on it yeah so what do you
think are some of the biggest
um problems and challenges the LGBT the
community is facing right now sure um I
honestly don't have an answer to that
but um the reason I'm asking is because
I'm in charge of the communications for
this so I just wanted to make sure like
I understand what you're using it for oh
all right well yeah you can ask people
and if they're not comfortable no I just
yeah I'm glad you're here I'm glad
you're doing the interview I just wanted
to make sure I understood what people
are being being asked that out that I
appreciate you yeah thank you what was
your name again
it was great meeting you absolutely
thanks for being here appreciate it yeah
of course thank you all right I I keto
those bullets you allow manipulation to
see where anybody wants you to go then
use your mind to break the Trap and
punish the perpetrator I saw the bullets
firing and I hit
do you think that there's an age that
kids should be able to transition or any
age
okay so like one thing I see a lot of
conservatives judge the lgbtq community
for is showing stuff to kids do you
think that's a problem or do you think
it should be the same or even more well
in my humble experience everyone in the
community is super child friendly so I
feel like a lot of the stuff that's like
risque for kids is propaganda that's not
really actually from the community you
get what I'm saying so I personally
don't think there's an age limit on what
like children should be exposed to uh he
him I is she here are you guys part of
the community or just here to support
the LGBT yeah I'm gay
here to support what do you think are
some of the biggest problems facing the
LGBT community right now on campus like
at our school like maybe acceptance and
acceptance yeah how can people be more
accepting I think doing what you just
did asking people's pronouns is a good
one of course I always ask for people's
pronouns nowadays yeah I think it's
important yeah and I think definitely I
mean nationally the sort of spin of
anti-trans and anti-queer legislation
pushing back on even like medically like
medically valid care and medically
endorsed care for especially minors who
need it for you know their own health
both their physical and their mental
health what are some of the anti-trends
and LGBT legislation being pushed right
now what kind of stuff is it I mean a
lot of it is like criminalizing uh
miners having gender affirming care so
such as puberty blockers testosterone
estrogen as well as like gender
affirming surgeries do you think that
there's an age that people should be
able to make that decision at I mean I I
don't really know I'm definitely not the
one to decide like this is the cutoff
you know what I mean I mean it's I think
it's so like if like let's say your
eight-year-old son said he's a boy and
he wants to get gender surgery to become
a girl like would you just go forward
with that I don't really know that would
definitely would be something that would
have to be like talked about with any
like doctors as well as psychologists
and things like that and the child
themself of course
I'm trapped in my body
I'll feel you I feel like a girl sir
Chop It Off
I think I've heard that kind of the
earlier that you affirmed someone's
identity like you prevent mental health
problems later down the line so the
earlier on the better not for surgery
but for affirming care yeah what's the
difference between affirming care and
surgery is that just hormones I'm not
exactly sure but just like dressing out
someone like okay so it's like dressing
as the other gender yeah okay awesome
thank you guys what was your name again
uh
you guys know my name we did a little
dance over there before
sunny but awesome thank you guys
we're just interviewing people with um
some questions do you want to be in it
it depends what's your agenda what's our
agenda we're just here to this is my
first ever Pride event so we're just
here to learn more okay I mean I feel
like you can ask anyone we've
interviewed and they'd say we've been
respectful and cool cool
I'm trying to learn more from the places
like how to be a better Ally
I'm just trying to learn more in general
okay
okay um yeah I'm happy to share
um my name is Jess I've been queer for
probably longer than you've been alive
um I hope that you use the information
you learn here in a way that helps lift
up the queer community and show that
what happens here is from a place of
love and care
that's kind of all I have to say are you
students are you yeah I mean the one
thing I'd say that I'm not the biggest
fan of since you know is is just like
showing this to kids so I think like
showing drag shows to kids isn't really
isn't really cool but that's the one
thing why why isn't that cool yeah
because I think that you shouldn't try
to push an agenda regarding sexuality
onto children why is that an agenda why
is that an agenda like why is drag
sexual
why is drought there was a little kid
twerking
like there was like she was like one of
the six-year-old girl was twerking over
there is that not sexual
am I am I crazy for saying that like I'm
really not trying to be rude here
I think that
we're talking about harmed kids there's
a lot of harm to kids that's out there
let's talk about school shootings let's
talk about things abuses of power
right like let's talk about priests
molesting kids that happens a lot of
course no I'm on board like I think that
those are all big problems so like one
thing that I see the conservatives
talking about the most is not showing
this stuff to kids because they don't
want
you know their kids getting getting in
their kids heads that they're
potentially trans because these people
believe that it's not born hold on hold
on hold on there's
okay let me explain something to you
guys okay being queer being trans is not
we're not trying to recruit okay
[Music]
not recruiting huh this was pretty
interesting when buying tickets to the
drag show we're buying the tickets to
the to the pride event right now and
look at this there's there's drag shows
and going on here let me get
tickets how do I get a discounted array
oh
three to eleven
should I just identify as a 10 year old
I guess so well that's why are
they even allowing kids at this I
think you guys are on like a fun little
train of like your white CIS male
privilege if I will you can like go
through the world and the world like
works with so then what's the point of
showing it to kids and stuff if there's
nothing hold on
showing it to kids because if you are
trans you are trans
you know the statistics of Health Care
that if you provide trans Health Care to
kids they are much less likely to commit
suicide do you know that
no I don't know the exact numbers
I see that term like
yeah okay so here's the deal if
we're if you're a lesbian gay bisexual
queer if you're trans if you're intersex
that's just who you are just like you
guys know I assume I don't want to
assume but I'm going to guess that
you're like CIS straight men you know
that
everybody else knows who they are I'm a
woman okay cool
um you're just a provocateur then and
you're an how am I an
because you're trying to antagonize
people here how am I antagonizing anyone
you can go ask anybody I interviewed
here's my point everybody oh my an
for my identity I don't I don't
understand that they are
and if you show people supportive that
it's okay to dance and wear makeup no
matter what genital Parts you have
people's obsession with sex and gender
the parts you have meaning the same
meaning that dictates who you are is
ridiculous just let people wear whatever
they are there's nothing inherently
sexual about dancing if you were
assigned male at Birth and wear makeup
that's my point the fact that you're
making it sexual is your problem
I'm the one making that sexual
maybe all right I'll have to do some
I'll have to I'll have to dive in and
and get deeper on that because I'm the
one I'm the one making toward making
kids to work and twerking in front of
kids not the one making sexual
yo thank you today
hey how'd I do you are amazing thank you
so much awesome thank you guys I'll see
you soon it's gonna be an interesting
boat ride back bro we're about to be
leaving Pride Island but real quick in
the last video I gave 500 of you guys
free access to one of my marketing cheat
codes I don't need to explain the rest
but that filled up near instantly so
right now I'm opening up another
thousand slots for you guys to get in
this is totally free by the way it's
just me sending you free information
about this cheat code that's generating
me five million dollars and a billion
views in a year so if you want to get
into this go to the top of the
description right now be real quick
and I'll see you let's get back to it
[Music]
why are you grabbing the camera
we're not taking advantage of anyone
we're taking advantage of
we're not doing anything
I got that on video
everyone is staring guys
for no reason all times right now I have
like 15 people looking at me I wasn't
even that bad bro I was like pretty
respectful we didn't do anything around
it
goodbye Pride Island and we we ain't
have nothing against like the members of
LGBT it just it's just the fact that
there was a little girl twerking and the
whole crowd was cheering that on that's
like and then and then where the one
sexualizing it all right boys that was
an absolutely insane video I cannot
believe all the stuff we saw uh oh we
got some coming up to us but thank you
guys so much for watching if you want
more videos like this make sure to drop
it in the comments below not for this
garbage
take this up
like I said there's a link to the
newsletter at the very top of the
description only a thousand people can
get in Crazy sauce in there as you guys
know I'm a master at going viral not to
toot my own horn but make sure you go it
it's free go go click it it's free and
I'll see you later
[Music]
and
foreign